Speaker 1: Let's hear from some of
the great people in our audience. We
do this on our Friday show. You can call
in through the David Pakman show Discord,
which by the way, you should join anyway
at David Pakman dot com slash discord.
Let's start today with Dan from Maryland.
Dan from Maryland, welcome to the program.
What is on your mind today? I'd love to
hear what what you've been thinking about.
Speaker 2: David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 2: All right. So you probably heard by now
that my mayor was arrested for child pornography.
Speaker 1: Your mayor, I don't
even know what city you live in.
Speaker 2: College Park, Maryland.
Speaker 1: Oh, no, I did not hear
about the College Park, Maryland movie.
Speaker 2: He was arrested about 50 counts
of child pornography. Wow. And I am absolutely
disgusted and disappointed because, you know,
I volunteered for him. I campaigned. I
voted. And you feel pretty gross, you know,
after this happens. But my my comment is
more of, you know, he is an openly gay
man. And I feel like this is kind of feeds the
narrative of, you know, the pedophile, you know,
homosexual that preys on children. And I feel
like with what's going on with the anti-trans
and the drag queen shows and the more of the
laws that are happening, I just feel like it's a
I don't know, a log on the fire. That makes.
Speaker 1: Sense. I totally understand what
you're saying. And of course, I mean, as as we
know, overwhelmingly the people arrested for
child porn are heterosexual. And I don't know
of anyone who is saying we have a problem with
with heterosexuals as a result of that. And one of
these things is what people create a narrative and
then they look only for examples that confirm it.
But this is the first I'm hearing of that story.
It sounds like like he's been charged but not
found guilty at this point in time. That's always
important to keep in mind when we talk about
these things. But you are without a doubt right,
that it will be a way to throw a log on the fire.
And that's the last thing we need right now.
Speaker 2: Yeah, because also 12 mayors so far
this year have also been arrested for similar,
I guess, actions as well. And it's just I know
it's just disappointing that, you know, you
live in a city and your mayor gets arrested. And
so, yeah. So I just want to say that, you know,
I don't really have a question. I just wanted to
put that out there. But I also want to say that
I'm a longtime listener and I'm glad that you are
keep going with the show and you do a great job.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much. Dan
from Maryland. Appreciate the call.
Speaker 2: You're welcome. Bye bye.
Speaker 1: All right, there goes Dan.